bello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo primissimo video del canale di
parigi tv se siete subisce le gaming
sappiate che questo video che state
vedendo è stato pubblicato due giorni fa
sul canale di famiglie tv
quindi se seguite il gaming per questo
genere di video passate sul mio canale
che trovate sin descrizione che nella
notazione in alto del video oh di qua oh
di qua sto facendo dei file a sordi
vabbè adesso vi spiego un po la
situazione comunque new game new game
boario lupi gamer paranormal brave te
sono fa vj però scelgo uno di questi
facciamo il gamer dai sono troppo
difficile
4 molti o due figure capi laplace wever
you never never seen before cosa faresti
se ti svegliassi in un posto dove non si
è mai stato prima di sicuro non
cercherei pagine a caso però come
presentimento che si può prendere a fare
proprio quello e perché boh che ne so
comunque ok ragazzi voglio soltanto di
visto videogame queensland around dovevo
farlo tipo due mesi fa minimo perché me
lo avete consigliato veramente in
tantissimi ragazzi due mesi fa più o
meno me l'avete consigliato in 50mila
però non l'ho fatto per problemi di
tempo è
adesso sono riuscito solo dopo due mesi
a farlo italiano un valore più farlo
perché ormai l'aveva già fatto tutti
però avevo promesso quindi almeno un
gameplay lo faccio allora eccola esse si
spegne la torcia perfetto passi avanti
ragazzi welcome to green park tomba di
scholl di mir ali got to find them and
asq for health come fai sapere che
qualcuno è qui vicino
ma perché c'è la macchina accesa scusate
oggi non connette ragazzi quel di scrubs
la bers il web tv other side of the gate
quale che il quale la convalle cancello
cos'è sta roba ragazzi
sì sì mi ricordo avevo visto degli
screen su svenderà mi pare che a
sinistra vadano le pagine dalla pagina
vanno a destra a sinistra vanno tipo di
oggetti che recuperino roba del genere
cos'è sta roba batterie uguale perché
mettono l'uno al posto della iucn si
capisce che sta roba qua 82 a ok ha
messo ma non devo trovare pagina mi sto
svendersi devono trovare foto ragazzi
non lo so boh no devo 12 scherzi sono 12
le paginette dei fogli comunque ok ho
capito praticamente devo trovare sia
delle foto che delle pagine comunque
l'importante che trovi le pagine poi se
trovare foto tanto meglio comunque qua
ragazzi c'è una macchina accesa una
accesa si sente il motore che fa la
macchina è accesa io non capisco perché
lui non prende semplicemente sta cazzo
di macchina e se ne va a minchia invece
no andiamo avanti e proprio adesso
andiamo a vedere ok perfetto questa era
il cancello di prima avete sentito cazzo
mia mi ha spiazzato questo urlo perché
non me l'aspettavo
c'è una bambina che è anche il pedofilo
slider e anche qui i ragazzi come
ribadisco come nel primo slam del che la
prima volta che vidi zoolander lo
scambia per un pedofilo e non si
smentisce ancora
ok siamo qui lato c è fatta male ragazzi
perché quando quando illumina illumina
troppo e quando non illumina non
illumina un cazzo quindi non riesco a
vedere comunque forse vedo meglio senza
siamo qui se devo andare animo sinistra
si diceva mi avete detto che lo slider
in questo videogame diversamente dagli
altri non appare ogni tre secondi quindi
non devo stare ogni tre secondi a
girarmi magari sto facendo un file
assurde appare più di prima è perché mi
state dando per il culo può succedere
però da quello che mi avete detto non
appare quasi mai è inoltre la mappa
questa qui è enorme e per questo penso
che ci hanno messo le indicazioni seno
uno non sa dove cazzo va allora siamo
qui si va beh non capisco ragazzi è
fatto
è questa chi l'aveva vista da dove sbuca
tassa casa ragazza aveva qua la luce
promette bene perfetto entriamo
vado è odio e raccapricciante sì
comunque avete ragione sembra che lo
slider non ne voglia sapere di apparire
ok
oddio ma che cosa è questo cioè ma
scusate una chiave perfetto lockout che
batteri wow c'è anche una scritta molto
bella sul muro don't back l'altro non si
capisce perché se illuminò non leggo se
non illumina non leggo non guardare
indietro ma non c'è nessuno perfetto
file di giornata ragazzi più c'era
nessuno fantastico c'è un furgone magari
questo ha voglia di prenderlo
diversamente dall'altro prova a uscire
dopo fatemi solo provare ad andare di
sua permesso accensione proteggere
migliori qua sta a casa e fantastiche
ragazze
ho una pagina una la prima 11 scrubs
left dovrebbe essere eleven scrubs left
my unisco l'italiano l'inglese in una
maniera tutta mia
e vabbè come si fa a su giusto piano qui
ragazzi non riescono a passato non si
può saltare
forse c'è un modo per girarlo di qua no
e allora cosa che faccio vado tipo così
grande mio dio ragazzi fa vj riesce ams
tipo peggio di essi o chi salta
impossibile improbabile zio chiude così
un'altra fonte fantastico
adesso lo fosse una chiave che non mi
serve a niente o va a capire ciò che ho
la chiave mi chiama questa servirà sta
cazzo di chiave cioè non ho capito
mettono le chiavi quelle tengo lì boh
non servono a niente
ragazzi è raccapricciante cioè guardate
in roba veramente studente rafah per
atmosfera streusel end e penso sia il
migliore finora c'è ha una grafica anche
se ha fatto quello unity che vi in
genere quelli con il video che ancora
giudici non è che una protesta
disponibilità grafica ma questo è
veramente fatto da dio
altro che tutti gli altri gen inter
messi insieme questo di batte tutti la
cosa [ __ ] ragazzi che a differenza degli
altri slider tu sei sperduto in un costo
enorme e poi decidere se andare a
ficcati dentro la foresta volesse andare
in giro c'è poi decidere tu cosa fare
questa la cosa [ __ ] che cazzo è sta roba
mio zio
ma cos'è ed il doe 2 the revenge
vi ricordate quello del primo slam
questo è ancora più alto allora stiamo
salendo insomma torre lo avete visto
anche voi interferenza
mi sembrava che ci fosse l'interferenza
ragazzi io mi muovo a salire perché non
è rassicurante
forse me la sono sognata e però poi da
può darsi che l'ho vista veramente non
so
continua a salire dicevo
non so cosa insieme perché c'è una torre
ma vabbè lasciamo stare
sta roba la sto cercando di salire da
un'ora è ancora non sono arrivate in
cima cazzo se mi butto da qui faccio red
bull stratos veramente ok allora c'è una
luce ad hoc a [ __ ] perfetto c'è un
divano e un'altra chiave perfetto the
back durkin e le chiare le batterie
perfetto allora anche una foto perfetto
cosa sembra una fabbrica cantano le
posse ingrandire fantastico insomma
salito per una torre no cazzo via
che culo che culo non ci posso credere
ragazzi ma questa mi piace solo per
questo
madonna che culo mi sono salvato in una
maniera incredibile
minchia mi pareva di esser caduto di
beni qua a me stesso ho passato in quel
non so più a parte il momento
riflessione che cazzo ci fa un divano su
una torre alta 50 metri se non di più
me lo spiegate e come mettere un divano
sopra la torre eiffel
solo che a quanto sta poi un lampione
voi spiegatemi cosa ma predicato come ci
hanno portato sul che ci ho messo due
ora a salire mi sono stancato io premere
il tasto per salire quelli che c'era un
portento proprio la nicchia ci saranno
suicidati poi perdona regione ecco
infatti c'è anche si vede qualcuno si è
buttato giù perché non c'era voglia di
nuovo di scendere comunque ragazzi si
posti sono sempre più nonsense prima
stavo per fare una brutta fine io ma mi
sa che quella bracciali sulla ringhiera
l'hanno fatta perché non c'erano più
voglia di scendere allora si sono
buttati direttamente risorto è comunque
ragazzi a differenza di una pagina e chi
cazzo l'aveva vista trend scrubs left
ragazzi mancano dieci pagine e siamo a
due non l'abbiamo vista sinceramente
ok miss mi sta andando il dito in
cancrena perché sto scendendo da un ora
amen allora ragazzi siamo la nostra
quasi mi fido perché ho fatto tanti di
quei tagli che non possono non fare
tagli in questo slider qui perché
talmente è talmente lungo che ci metto
troppo tempo a farlo a un'altra cosa
raga non è come gli altri lander che
dopo 10 secondi di corsa cade a terra
sfinito come se avesse fatto le
olimpiadi a differenza degli altri
sander questo dura di più nella corsa
diciamo ok c'è un bivio non ci sono
indicazioni e vado di qui me ne vado
vado via da al posto tutti incasinato
perfetto ok siamo una luce vedo una luce
oddio oddio c'è una pagina abbiamo maria
grazia
guess il web per p 20 style name scrò
plugin ragazzi davvero non mi faccio
capace di come di come possa essere
arrivato fino a questo punto addirittura
tre pagine senza morire un videogame
difficilissima anche perché cose lander
e mi ha messo proprio alle strette non
si è vista una volta ragazza va bene che
non deve essere bella gli altri slam che
si vede poco anzi molto meglio che si
veda poco però c'è almeno quella volta
che appare dovrebbe farti venire un
infarto ma non appare c'è la boe
apparirà al momento giusto ci sono altre
pagine ragazzi però prima o poi apparirà
di sicuro io proseguo batterie perfetto
sì va beh siamo qua siamo c'è un
c'è un qualcosa che lampeggia li ho
paura di andare a vedere non sa che
cos'è lo vedete c'è una luce forse
qualcuno che tenta di di comunicare con
l'alfabeto morse cos'è è una nota
televisore ma perché se ci fa un
televisore in mezzo a un campo su un
comodino
ma poi scusate ragazzi ma che cos'è
cazzo è collegato non c'è l'antenna
perché un televisore vecchie non mi pare
sia un malato ma sembra più in forno a
microonde o cazz o cazzo cazzo cazzo
dove vedo vedo vedo ok ok ok ok ok vedo
interferenza ragazzi dovrei averlo
dietro lo slider mi chiami sono preso un
infarto
non ho visto le ringrazio dio di non
averlo visto amici sul cuore a mille
ragazzi
oddio cosa è successo la visura non ho
visto niente cazzo che ne vado di qua
allora siamo è difficile da capire vado
devo andare di qua per forza perché deve
esserci un edificio tra nelle vicinanze
chi meno di quando non capisco dove
perché difficile comunque interpretarle
se va bene ok sento dei rumori
bruttissimi cos'è quello vedo una pagina
sento davies figli o cazzo è un ora se
ho sentito ora qualcuno che ha piantato
corrotto era non so un orco qualcosa del
genere con qui nella foresta non ci
entrerò più questo è sicuro avevo visto
una casa sembrava aver visto un'ombra
nella foresta
perché io ne vado ci sembrava di aver
visto una casa lontananza laggiù vedo
bene un'ombra non capisco se una casa
allora questo cos'è questo una baracca
qua a un'altra pagina ragazzi sei mica
ragazzi sei pagine po dj province va a
finire all'inter ho avuto al primo
tentativo mai giocato
ok me ne sto tirando da solo ragazzi
meglio che non dico niente ma che cazzo
ma dove sono finito cos'è sto costo
medio ma che ma che posso dai ragazzi ma
perché ci sono
di luci le luci tutte che lampeggiano e
non c è un app che funziona normalmente
ragazzi le luci tutte che vanno
interferenza tutte che lampeggiano non
ce n'è una che funziona
non è che possono mettere luci normali
se non sono contenti cioè io sto girando
da un'ora perché non trovo l'entrata
però se da una parte ci sono delle
batterie da dentro però non posso
entrare di quando perfetto ragazzi devo
fare il giro perché non riesco ad
entrare visto anche cagando addosso
perché sento dei rumori sempre più non
lo so come descriverlo rumori di fondo
che sono paurosi a dir poco comunque
passano di qua a chi dovrei essere
entrato si perfetto
ok pieno di barili e vabò qua non ci
sono batteri non c'è niente c'è una
porta ma io di qua non ci hai chiuso
perfetto o due chiavi ma sono lì per
bellezza non le usiamo
dopo anni di qua ci sarà un entrata
presto posto enorme cioè non capisco
perché cosa l'hanno fatto a fare sennò
batterie perfetto poi mi spiegate perchè
esce il sangue dai vari di però perché
sono dettagli luci che non funzionano
tutte non funzionale che ci sono tutte
le interferenze permesso al razzo post è
molto carino si perfetto e molto ampio
figlio altro o un'altra pagina ragazzi
55 ne mancano fives krapp's last sto per
cui non ci credo che sia arrivato
veramente così lontano
vabbè che ha perso soltanto una volta è
quella volta che abbassa non l'ho visto
però veramente non mi aspettavo di
arrivare così lontano
lo stesso forse doveva aumentare la
difficoltà ma ho messo che ai nar quindi
non è neanche troppo facile c'erano nov
roub c'era nube paranormal again è
rimesso kaymer che era quella di mezzo
quindi va beh non è neanche netro papà
ti proponi c'entrano armada per essere
un primo tentativo non è male dai
diciamo potremmo dire da un momento
all'altro i maestro tirando addosso una
dopo l'altra ragazzi allora sto salendo
nel in
salendo sulle travi di legno il perché
non lo so neanche io però lo sto facendo
niente proseguiamo avranno una fine cioè
l'edificio non è enorme
le luci che lampeggia hanno offerto let
me go è una canzone di nichi in parquet
un messaggio oddio c'è un'altra pagina
web force la flat
ok ragazzi devo scendere seccato a marzo
già prima ci sono andato vicino e sulla
torre però meglio scendere perchè devo
non so dove andare da gas che è talmente
enorme posto che non ha forse pro grande
di questa porta qui va le luci che
ovviamente per è chiusa mi dimetto
perché non posso aprire le porte perché
ho due chiavi che sarà uno solo per per
tenerle lì ferme
allora che ne so facciamo il giro che si
possa fare il giro no ha invece sì si
può fare giro allora che il caso serve
sopporta e che seguiamo ci sono ci sono
delle batterie perfetto
si ok altra porta scommetto chiusa ma
guarda caso e non si apre proprio vero
il mio dio che sorpresa qualche ai
ragazzi ci sono dice un posto lì non
vedo bene che cosa c'è comunque ci
saranno di sicuro minimo una pagina però
non posso entrarci ovviamente perché le
mie chiavi sono inutili forse forse
riesco a passare di qua strano che cazzo
era io a volte per interferenze non so
se me le sogno forse sono vere
cazzo